ANDREW HUBERMAN: Welcome
to the Huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science
and science-based tools
for everyday life.
ANDREW HUBERMAN:
Recently, the Huberman Lab
hosted a live event at
the Meridian Theater
in Toronto, Ontario.
The event consisted of a
lecture entitled "The Brain Body
Contract" followed by a
question and answer session.
We wanted to make sure that the
question and answer session was
available to
everybody regardless
of who could attend in person.
I also want to
make sure to thank
the sponsors of that event,
which were AG1 and Eight Sleep.
Eight Sleep makes smart mattress
covers with cooling, heating,
and sleep tracking capacity.
One of the key things to
getting a great night's sleep
is to make sure that the
temperature of your sleeping
environment is correct.
And that's because in order to
fall and stay deeply asleep,
your body temperature
actually has
to drop by about one
to three degrees.
And in order to wake up feeling
refreshed and energized,
your body temperature
actually has
to increase by about
one to three degrees.
With Eight Sleep, you can
program the temperature
of your sleeping environment
in the beginning, middle,
and end of your night.
It has a number of other
features like tracking
the amount of rapid eye
movement and slow wave
sleep that you get,
things that are
essential to really dialing
in the perfect night's
sleep for you.
I've been sleeping on
an Eight Sleep mattress
cover for well
over two years now,
and it has greatly
improved my sleep.
I fall asleep far more quickly.
I wake up far less often
in the middle of the night,
and I wake up feeling
far more refreshed
than I ever did prior to using
an Eight Sleep mattress cover.
If you'd like to
try Eight Sleep,
you can go to
eightsleep.com/huberman to save
$150 off their Pod 3 Cover.
Eight Sleep currently
ships to the USA,
Canada, UK, select countries
in the EU, and Australia.
Again, that's
eightsleep.com/huberman.
AG1 is an all in one vitamin
mineral probiotic drink.
I've been taking AG1
since 2012, so I'm
delighted that they
sponsored the live event.
The reason I started taking
AG1 and the reason I still
drink AG1 once or
twice a day is that it
provides all of my
foundational nutritional needs.
That is, it provides
insurance that I
get the proper amounts of those
vitamins, minerals, probiotics,
and fiber to ensure optimal
mental health, physical
health, and performance.
If you'd like to try AG1, you
can go to drinkag1.com/huberman
to claim a special offer.
They're giving away five
free travel packs plus
a year's supply
of Vitamin D3+K2.
Again, that's
drinkag1.com/huberman to claim
that special offer.
And now without further ado,
the question and answer session
from our live event
at the Meridian
Theater in Toronto, Ontario.
OK.
What motivated me to do the
guest series with Paul Conti?
OK.
So first of all, for those
of you that don't know,
Paul Conti is a psychiatrist.
He's a Stanford and Harvard
trained psychiatrist,
and I wanted to do the series
with Paul for several reasons,
and we initiated that series.
First of all, he's incredibly
talented as a clinician.
And yet despite having written
an excellent book about trauma,
I felt that two things
were true for sure.
One is that most people
won't get the opportunity
to work with Paul, sadly.
He's time limited.
And second is that his expertise
is incredibly vast not just
restricted to trauma.
Traumas, if understood,
can be transmuted
into deep sources of knowledge
that other people can
benefit from.
Indeed, what I found in
Paul as I got to know
him is that he has
just profound insight
into the unconscious mind.
And people had long asked me
in and around the podcast,
what about the subconscious?
What about the unconscious?
And I was of the mind
that the supercomputer
of the human brain is the
forebrain, the thinking,
planning, context, setting
piece right behind our forehead.
It's the reason that
we're not the house cats.
The house cats are
the house cats,
and it's the reason we're
the curators of the planet.
But Paul said, oh,
no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
The unconscious mind is the
supercomputer of the mind.
I'm like, well,
that sounds great.
But how do we understand
the unconscious mind?
And he has a really
biological and
psychological and
psychiatric understanding
of the unconscious.
And in that series, he talks
about these so-called cupboards
that we can look into in
order to better understand
our unconscious mind
in order to allow
our unconscious mind to teach
us things about ourselves that
are useful.
And there are three main places
where our unconscious teaches
us useful things that allow us
to be more conscious of the way
that our brain is
working in useful ways.
The first is in
these liminal states
between waking and sleep.
It really does
seem to be the case
that when, surprise, surprise,
we're completely still
and we're emerging from or we're
dropping into states of reduced
autonomic arousal but our
level of thought, if you will,
is still active enough that
we are aware maybe even
lucid dreams and also in dreams,
our unconscious mind uses,
as I think Jung and Freud
pretty well understood,
symbols to teach us things.
But everything's
flipped in there.
Gender's flipped.
Just because you're having
a conflict with somebody
in your life who's
a man doesn't mean
that person shows up as a man.
They could show up as an
animal, so species are flipped.
The symbols become
mishmashed, but Paul
made it very clear
that all this can
be parsed if you do a certain
kind of introspective work.
And I thought that would
mean a lot of talk therapy.
How are we going to get
people to learn how to do
talk therapy by themselves?
We want to keep things as much
independent of cost and things
like that.
And the practices he
started talking about
were incredibly simple.
Things like mirror work--
some of the
psychologists in the room
will be familiar with this.
I thought, mirror work?
What is that?
And he said, literally,
people trying
to access their unconscious in
sleep by a practice of staring
into the mirror for some
period of time while awake
and reflecting on
self and aspirations
and the idea of the
body as a container.
All this stuff, even for a
kid from Northern California,
sounds really, woo, new agey.
But here, it's scripted by
Paul into a formal structure
that one can use to parse
your own mental health
and enhance mental health.
So that was the reason
for doing the series.
And especially the episode
on relationships, not just
romantic relationships,
I found--
hasn't come out yet.
Incredibly
interesting, because he
talked about how in his
clinical experience,
virtually all the stuff
that people pay attention
to in relational stuff
is, are they a narcissist?
Are they obsessive?
Is this person a musician
versus whether or not
I'm an accountant?
Are we compatible?
That none of that stuff predicts
anything as well as the balance
of these three drives--
the aggressive drive,
the pleasure drive,
and the so-called
generative drive.
And I found it to
be fascinating,
and I'm excited for that
episode and the other episodes
to come out.
But basically, because
Paul is brilliant.
And he makes what I consider
pretty obscure and opaque
very clear and
concrete, and there
are a bunch of worksheets--
again, all available at zero
cost and none of them
requiring that you do therapy
with anybody if
you choose not to.
This is all the kind of work
that one could do on oneself.
And the last thing I'll
say about this is--
and I should have
said this first--
is that the primary motivation
was we did a series of Dr. Andy
Galpin on physical fitness.
Why isn't there a series
on mental fitness?
What is that?
Why do we talk so much
about mental health when
we're-- and it's usually a
conversation about mental
illness.
People should have tools and
practices that are zero cost,
I believe, to be able to
introspect in a structured way
and enhance their mental
health independent
of their level of
income, and I think
Paul was the guy to do it.
And we'll do more of
that with other people
as well because no single
episode about any topic
or series can exhaustively
cover any topic, although Lord
knows we will try.
OK.
Next question.
What are the recommended
protocols and best practices
to enhance emotional resilience
and develop effective responses
during highly
triggering situation?
You're asking the wrong guy.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, I don't snap.
I don't snap.
I was a wild teenager,
but I don't snap.
I'm not the aggressor, but
I do have a snap button,
and it's been pushed before.
And I have to say
when that happens,
it's really kind
of a scary thing.
Not to me, right?
And it's been many years.
But I think anyone who's
hit that threshold where
you're trying not to say
something, you say it anyway.
That's usually how it
shows up for people.
I think we hear the statements.
Be responsive, not reactive.
That's why I became a
biologist because stuff
like that makes no sense to me.
In that moment, how are you
responsive, not reactive?
So to me, it was like,
what are the tools?
Clearly, as you go up that
continuum of autonomic arousal,
it becomes much harder to do
whatever that means, right?
Hence, the tools for
reducing stress in real time.
I think the one that
we haven't emphasized
so much on the podcast--
and by the way, thanks to some
great therapy that was not
voluntary, I was able to--
I was a wild kid.
I was a wild, wild kid.
I hung around wild kids, and
things were pretty different
then, and we worked it out.
But I think nowadays,
it's wonderful
because I think people are
more conscious of the need
to understand their nervous
system, their own psychology.
That wasn't as common back then.
In fact, I hid the fact
that I had to do therapy
for a long time, thinking, wow.
Everyone's going
to think I'm crazy.
They did call me crazy.
I think things have
really changed.
I think the last 20
years have brought
about a profound
shift in the way
that we think about
our own species
and what our useful
tools and practices.
And I think that one of the
things that is abundantly clear
is that threshold
for a stress response
really is different
for different people,
different in
different situations,
but that it is something
that can be practiced
and elevated in terms of not
getting near that trigger point
through the types of practices
that I talked about earlier.
Getting more comfortable
with adrenaline
circulating in your system
is what it's really about,
frankly.
But of course, it all starts
with a good night's sleep,
right?
It's going to make
you far less reactive.
But of course, when
you're stressed,
that's often when you're
not getting good sleep.
So I think ultimately
that our ability to--
as more emotional resilience
and effective responses
during triggering
situations is really
the consequence of practices
of taking good care
outside of those situations.
And then of course,
inevitably, there
will be situations where
people get triggered.
And it's actually interesting to
see the way that people behave
online and the fact that many
people, in fact, in science
as well have literally lost
their jobs for not being
able to control their thumbs.
We're in an odd
time where there's
the distancing of doing things
online as opposed to in person
where people somehow engage in
saying things and doing things
that they wouldn't in person.
But I think that ultimately it's
the consequence of good self
care, and this
gets actually back
to some of the things that are
covered in the Conti series.
We hear about self care.
We think that means massages,
which are great, by the way.
And we think that is about
exercise, and that's wonderful.
But much of self care is
about really making sure
that our nervous
system is in the state
that we need it to be in
order to go about our day.
And I think this is why morning
routines and practices are
so vital.
I think that those set the stage
for the emotional resilience.
Those set the stage for avoiding
getting triggered, so to speak.
I don't think there's
a lot that one
can do in real time except
perhaps physiological sighs.
So sorry to give you a
sort of empty answer.
I'm not a pessimist
on this front.
But I think that
ultimately, it's
like saying, well,
what if you have
to scale the side of
a building to get in
and you locked yourself out?
What can you do to
prepare for that?
Well, you can buy a ladder.
But if you don't have a ladder,
what you probably should do
is be physically fit
enough to climb up
a railing or something like
that and know how to pick
a lock or something like that.
So I think ultimately that it's
the consequence of stuff that's
done away from those
triggering situations.
Next question, please.
How would you describe the
brain activity of somebody
when they're suddenly
inspired, and how do you foster
inspiration in your life?
Well, I talked a
little bit about this,
but I will say that the best
way to foster inspiration
is in the words of the
great Joe Strummer.
They actually call it
Strummer's law, no joke.
No input, no output.
I think one of the
things that I've
observed over and over
again is that as much
as we need to dedicate ourselves
to our craft, to our families,
to our friends, that
ultimately our best ideas come
from disparate
experiences when we're not
seeking a particular kind
of input to get ideas.
Now, maybe, this
practice of being
completely still while being
alert fosters a lot of--
I think the way I
understand it is
more of a geysering up of stored
information in the unconscious.
That's how I think Rick
would talk about it
or Paul Conti would talk
about it, as geysering up
from the unconscious.
Because when we are focused
on the outside world,
we're taking in
sensory information,
exteroception as opposed
to interoception.
Of course, that external sensory
information-- that no input,
no output--
is that those are
the raw materials
that our nervous system uses to
construct ideas about anything.
So my belief-- and
this is a practice
I do every week is I make sure
that at least once a week I
either walk or hike or
run without any earphones.
And I'm trying to get into
states of wordlessness,
states where I'm not
digesting a podcast,
where I'm not reading a
book, where I'm not listening
to a lecture, where I'm
not in conversation,
and essentially, trying to turn
off the linguistic narrative.
We are a storytelling species.
We tend to take all of
our internal and external
experience and construct
things around language.
But spoken language is not the
language of the nervous system.
The language of
the nervous system
still remains to be identified.
It's something else.
For people that think in
feels, it will certainly
incorporate that.
Spoken language, of
course, is important,
and we have some core
structures to spoken language.
We covered this in
the podcast episode
with my friend Eddie Chang.
But ultimately the way
to come up with new ideas
or inspiration is going to be
to collect the raw materials
of experience and then give
ourselves these periods,
maybe even just
five, 10 minutes--
you don't have to lay around
half the day doing nothing
still wide awake--
and give that those raw
materials the opportunity
to marinate and combine
in whatever ways
that are unique to you
and then to geyser up.
What inspiration looks
like in the brain,
we don't really know.
There's awe.
There are some studies about
awe, but that's different.
The word that better
comes to mind is delight.
Awe in my mind is something
that we witness that sort
of overwhelms our attention.
Like, wow.
Delight is when it
somehow links up
with our own internal narrative.
Like, I have something to
do with what's happening.
I'm not just here to witness it.
A really impressive
fireworks show is like awe,
but there's nothing
to do about it.
It doesn't relate to
anything about you, really.
You're purely a spectator.
Whereas delight is
when you see something
and it somehow
links to something
in your emotional or personal
history or how you're wired,
that now there's
something to do about it.
That's inspiration.
And we don't understand where
that exists in the brain
or what that looks
like, but I think we all
recognize that feeling
when it happens,
and it's oh so wonderful.
OK.
Next question, please.
How can Canadians fight
the seasonal depression?
Winters are too long here.
OK.
Well, this gives
me an opportunity
to share with you
what I think is
one of the coolest
things about our species.
Notice I say that
about many things.
So we've talked about
circadian rhythms, right?
Sunrises, sunsets.
And we get that
information transmitted
into our nervous system
by looking at the sunrise.
By the way, you
don't have to watch
the sun cross the horizon.
It just needs to be low
solar angle, low in the sky.
Once it's overhead,
it's a different signal.
So low solar angle,
that's what it's about.
It's not necessarily
about seeing
the sun cross the horizon.
By the way, someone the
other day on my team said,
won't you get cataracts
if you look at the sun?
Low solar angle sunlight is very
unlikely to cause cataracts,
especially if you're just
doing it 10 to 30 minutes.
The sun overhead is
when it's quite bright.
Yes, indeed, some
people are going
to be at risk for cataracts.
So ophthalmologists
in the audience
can attack me for that one.
But it was our chair of
ophthalmology at Stanford
that said it, so I'm
going to trust him.
OK.
That's circadian,
24 hour rhythms.
But there's also these
circannual rhythms.
So if you're at a
fairly northern location
on the planet,
nights get very long.
Days get short in winter.
What happens then?
Well, melatonin, the
hormone of darkness,
is essentially
obliterated by sunlight.
So what's happening when
days are 12 hours long,
you have very little melatonin,
the duration of the melatonin
signal is very short?
Then as you proceed into the
fall, days are getting shorter.
Nights are getting longer.
The duration of the
melatonin signal
is getting longer and longer.
Then, of course, in winter,
there's a lot more darkness.
Melatonin signals are very long.
Daylight signals are very short
because the days are short.
So you can say, OK.
Well, that's obvious,
thank goodness.
But what that means
is incredible.
What that means is that you
have a hormone, melatonin,
that's secreted from your pineal
gland, which Descartes called
the seat of the
soul because there's
only one of them in the brain.
I don't know how he
up with that one.
But the pineal
secretes melatonin,
and you suppress
melatonin secretion
with sunlight viewing.
There's a couple of synapses in
between the eye and the pineal,
but it gets there up
through the neck, basically,
the cervical ganglia.
What's wild, therefore,
is that the location
of the Earth around the sun
and the tilt of the Earth
is translated into a neural
and then a hormonal signal
in your brain, which
to me is amazing.
That literally means
that the position
of the Earth around
the sun and its tilt
are translated into a
physiological signal that's
working unconsciously to tell
your brain and body what time
of year it is.
But it doesn't care
what time of year it is.
It cares about where you are
in this orbit about the sun.
So if you think about
when days are, say,
eight hours long in the
fall versus eight hours long
in the spring, what's different?
What's different is how long
the signal was the day before.
So the seasonal
depression we now know
is the consequence of the
melatonin signal getting
longer, not an absolute duration
of the melatonin signal.
In other words, in the spring
when a day is eight hours long,
but yesterday, the day was
seven hours and 48 minutes long,
your brain has a memory
of how much melatonin
was released the
day before, much
more than that particular day.
So it's a slow
integrating clock.
So this is a very
roundabout way for me
to teach you about the
melatonin seasonal rhythm cycle
and answer the question
directly by saying,
if you want to offset
seasonal depression,
what you want to do is extend
the amount of bright light
that you're getting
in the morning
slightly as days get shorter.
But it's the extension of
the bright light exposure--
and if you can't do that
with sunlight because there's
no sunlight because
you live in Toronto,
not Toronto, what you want to do
is find some artificial source
that you can look
at in the morning
before you leave your home.
And I haven't talked much
about this on the podcast
because our listeners
are extended it
around the globe and not
just in northern locations.
But what this essentially
means is getting maybe
two to three minutes of bright
light exposure as you're
heading from fall into winter--
bright light from an
artificial source.
You do not need to
purchase a so-called SAD
lamp, one of these very
expensive seasonal depression
lamps.
What I did was I
purchased-- because I'm
very sensitive to
seasonal changes in light
even though I don't
live very far north.
You can get a 900
lux drawing tablet.
These are quite inexpensive.
They're not zero cost,
but quite inexpensive.
And just put that on
your desk or on wherever
you make your coffee in
the morning 90 minutes
after you wake up--
this sort of thing.
And just get five or so minutes
before you leave the house.
And then as you extend
into the winter,
you don't have to be
neurotic about increasing
the duration every day.
Actually, the way these slow
integrating clocks work,
you could actually even just
hold it a little bit closer
each day.
Don't burn your eyeballs out--
a little bit closer each day.
But essentially, if you just
dose yourself with a little bit
more bright light early in the
day as you extend into winter,
that will essentially
trick the melatonin system
into thinking that you're
going from eight hours
into 10 hours of light
as opposed to eight hours
into six hours of light.
OK?
Very simple.
And if you can't get one
of these 900 lux tablets
or something off a
website, then you
could do this with any bright
incandescent bulb should work.
Again, just be careful
not to put it directly
against your eyeball.
OK.
Next question, please.
How do you increase
neuroplasticity?
Well, this is an opportunity
to talk about something
I should have said earlier,
which is that ultimately,
whether or not you are
triggering neuroplasticity
through elevated focus
or whether or not you're
taking high dose psilocybin--
your business, not mine.
And we can talk about
psychedelics if you want--
just decriminalized
in California
or soon to be decriminalized.
[CHEERS]
Cool.
People are enthusiastic.
Yeah.
I've been pretty
vocal about my belief
that the data are
really interesting,
to say the least,
about not microdosing.
By the way, there's
not a lot of evidence
that microdosing is useful.
I'm not saying
it's not, but there
not a lot of clinical
trials showing that.
But the two macro dose with
effective therapeutic support
trials are very encouraging
not just for major depression
but also for various
eating disorders,
alcohol use disorder, which
is, by the way, the term
that people are
starting to shift
to as opposed to alcoholism--
alcohol use disorder.
Which is not to be
politically correct,
just so you understand
what they're
talking about when they're
talking about alcohol use
disorder.
Whether or not psilocybin,
whether or not it's MDMA,
whether or not it's frustration
brought about by your inability
to play an instrument and
your determination to do so,
in the end, it's
all about deployment
of these neuromodulators,
neuromodulators
being some combination
of dopamine, serotonin,
acetylcholine, or epinephrine,
again, usually in combination.
What's very clear is that
the neuroplastic effects
of MDMA, the neuroplastic
effects of psilocybin
are brought about by huge
increases in serotonin.
This also can help us
understand why, for some years,
and to some extent still
now, it was thought
that the SSRIs, the selective
serotonin reuptake inhibitors,
would be good treatments
for depression.
I think some people,
by the way, have
experienced tremendous
relief from the SSRIs.
We don't want to demonize them.
At the same time,
it's very clear
that depression is not simply
low levels of serotonin.
That's also not true, hence
why there's effective,
in some people, antidepressants
like bupropion that
increase dopamine and
epinephrine and not serotonin.
The point here is that these
neuromodulators, as they're
called, allow for what?
They allow for modulation of
synapses, which effectively
allows for neuroplasticity.
I mean, ultimately
whether or not
it's through talk therapy,
Kundalini breathing, high dose
psilocybin, MDMA,
or the combination,
which I think is
called a hippy flip--
[LAUGHTER]
Never done them together.
I confess.
Never done them
together, but have
done them with a
clinician, by the way,
in legal circumstances.
And not a lot--
not often, that is.
It's very clear that it's
opening windows for plasticity.
Now, what's intriguing, if
we're going to just talk
about psychedelics
for a second, is
why a drug like
MDMA, which increases
dopamine-- which,
by the way, MDMA is
methylenedioxymethamphetamine.
Don't let anybody tell you
it's something different.
It's meth.
But it's meth with a lot of
serotonin thrown in there, too.
But it's meth.
And it's clear that for
the treatment of PTSD,
it holds promise.
It's not absolutely
safe, especially
for people with
cardiac conditions.
If you're going to
go down that path,
you want and need
a skilled guide,
and this is where I
think the laws are really
going to have to pay
careful attention to who
and what is a skilled guide, OK?
And when it comes to psilocybin,
the serotonin increase
is what effectively causes
broader connectivity
in the brain.
And what's interesting is
that both of those drugs
increase plasticity mainly
through increases in serotonin
but working on very
different receptors.
So they have different types
and outputs of plasticity.
What's interesting to
me is that-- because I'm
a strong believer that
children should not
be doing psychedelics nor
should we be giving children
psychedelics-- is that the
increases in connectivity
in the brain that are the
consequence of playing
a musical instrument,
or ideally,
an instrument with
others as a child,
mimic a lot of the broader
scale connectivity, sort
of so-called resting
network connectivity, that
occurs when people take
psychedelics as adults.
In other words-- and I
can't emphasize this enough.
And again, I failed
at music miserably.
I'll tell you a story
about that in a second.
Getting kids to
play an instrument--
it's very clear it
improves their ability
to learn all sorts of things
for their entire life.
It's just so, so important.
I don't really know
what to do about this
or who to shout at or
talk to about keeping
the arts active in schools
and physical education.
But the idea that we would
just train kids in math
is just frightening
because if you
want them to be truly
good at math and science,
you'd also have them
play instruments.
By the way, when I was a
kid, I played the violin.
My parents made me.
It was not the instrument.
I wanted to play, and we
have only one picture.
They taught me
the Suzuki method.
You're supposed to learn by ear.
And there's one picture,
and all the other kids
have their bows up.
And my bow is down, and I'm
standing here on the stage,
and my fly is down.
And literally, the
neighbor's dog howled,
and I quit after that concert.
So I was traumatized by it.
They showed me the picture.
My sister teased
me relentlessly.
So neuroplasticity--
figure out your choice way
to increase a neuromodulator
like serotonin or epinephrine,
acetylcholine, or dopamine.
I honestly would not encourage
pharmacologic or psychedelic
approaches as your
primary entry point.
I really don't.
I think that there's a place for
that in certain circumstances,
but that would not be
the primary entry point.
Next question, please.
What type of movement
protocol do you
recommend for somebody
who is working
from home sitting behind the
computer from 8:00 AM to 5:00
PM.
Oh.
OK.
Well, a couple of things.
I mean, I can make all
sorts of recommendations,
like get up early and move, if
you can take breaks and walk,
this sort of thing.
But let's assume
that all of that
is kind of
understood, that there
are certain forms of exercise
that we should all be doing.
I think now, it's very clear
based on the beautiful work
of Peter Attia, whose
brother is in the audience,
by the way, tonight.
Yeah.
[CHEERS]
He's got a younger brother.
Can you imagine if Peter
Attia was your older brother?
Can you imagine?
That'd be pretty cool.
I sort of adopt
people as siblings.
They don't know it, but I do.
But I just assume Peter was my
older brother, but turns out he
has a younger brother already.
And Peter has
essentially hammered home
the truth, which is
that we should all
be getting somewhere
between 150 to 200 minutes
of so-called zone 2 cardio
where we're walking a lot
and/or moving about
where we can just
barely hold a conversation.
I notice people in Toronto seem
to walk a lot, so that's great.
And then three days a
week or so of resistance
training, and there are a
bunch of other mobility things
that we should all do so that
we don't fall and break our hips
or another bone because that's
another way that people really
limit their health span and life
span and so on and so forth.
But two things
that can make being
at a desk-- which I loathe.
Even though I like to
learn, I hate sitting still.
You can do the
standing desk thing.
I do that by stacking boxes.
The other thing that
was interesting--
did anyone see this study out
of the University of Texas?
I think it was Houston this last
year about the soleus push up.
Did anyone see this?
This is pretty interesting.
So the soleus, this
wider flat muscle
below the gastrocnemius
of the calf,
is a really unique
muscle in the human body.
It's 1% of the total
human musculature,
but it has an ability--
what will soon be
for obvious reasons--
to dramatically shift fuel
utilization in the body.
What they did in
this study was they
had people who were sitting for
three or four hours a day just
simply raise their heel.
Seems almost silly, right?
They call it a soleus push up.
When I called it that
online, I literally
got attacked by the
gym bros telling me
that's a seated calf raise.
OK?
OK.
No wonder this whole bro science
thing gets kind of-- people
get really aggressive.
They lift their heel, and
they're pushing their toe down.
And some people think of
it as bouncing the knee,
but it's really about pushing
the toe down and lifting
the heel.
So they just simply
had these sedentary
people do this heel raise.
And what they saw
was that there was
a dramatic, highly statistically
significant increase in blood
glucose utilization and
reduction in both insulin
levels during that activity
and around the clock.
Really interesting.
What they were
doing was mimicking
some aspect of walking.
Now, is it as good as walking?
No.
But if you are stuck behind--
working from home, sitting
behind the computer
from 8:00 AM to
5:00 PM, what they
found was that people
getting into this unconscious
pattern of lifting
their heel over and over
and shifting back and
forth mimicked a lot
of the effects of walking.
It's not a replacement
for exercise,
but the shifts in glucose and
insulin utilization and output
respectively were
very impressive.
And this group down
at the University
of Houston at University
of Texas in Houston
is starting to incorporate
this into people
who have limited mobility.
And it doesn't seem like other
limb movements can do this.
There's something
special about the soleus.
It was designed, in air
quotes, to be a muscle that's
used repeatedly over
extended hours of time
and that has this unique
pathway of fuel utilization.
So is it going to cure obesity?
No.
But if you're stuck
behind a desk,
that would be something useful.
I have this little fidget thing.
I was too lazy to build
one, but I found one
online for a couple
of bucks where
you just when you
stand at your desk
and just kind of kick
it back and forth.
Anyone seen these?
These are kind of cool.
Then you just kind of
kick them back and forth.
And some people will
treadmill at the desk.
I can't do that.
I can't do that many things.
But I also am still
working on this one.
I can't quite do that.
Next question, please.
My morning meditation
consists of--
OK.
And then I think we're
about out of time.
Yeah.
So my morning meditation
is not really a meditation,
it's a perceptual exercise.
And that perceptual
exercise has a weird name
because I gave it a weird name.
And I didn't intend
to sound mystical,
and I don't want credit for it.
But I call it space time
bridging, but it's not that.
To me, one of the most
interesting things
about the nervous
system is our ability
to orient in different
time domains.
This gets a little bit abstract.
But we know from
states of high stress
that we start fine slicing time.
We know this, right?
The world becomes like
a slow motion video
because frame rate
has increased.
As a vision neuroscientist,
I can tell you
that in my laboratory,
we were doing studies
with virtual reality
where we can crank up
people's level of
stress by giving them
certain visual stimuli,
and then their ability
to parse information is clearly
increasing in the time domain.
They're fine slicing
much in the same way
that when you look at a slow
motion video of somebody
dunking a basketball or
something of that sort,
it's because the
frame rate went up.
So when we are in
high alertness states,
our frame rate increases.
When we're very relaxed,
our frame rate decreases.
So if you're Rick
Rubin and you're
lying there looking at
the sky, your frame rate
is probably slower
than if you're hyper
focused on-- oh my goodness.
Imagine a dreadful situation
where somebody sends you
a text message.
Well, let's make it positive.
Somebody is having a
child in your family.
And you're like, is it healthy?
Are mom and baby OK?
Dot, dot, dot.
I mean, seconds
feel like minutes.
Minutes feel like hours because
you're fine slicing time.
OK?
And then mom and baby are fine.
OK, great.
Happy story ending.
Great.
So when we're very relaxed, we
tend to bend time more broadly.
Now, it's also true
that your visual system
and your perception of time
are inextricably linked
such that if you close
your eyes and you
focus on your internal state,
you are fine slicing time.
And the second
hand, if you will,
is more or less-- the
metronome, rather,
is your breathing and
your heart rate combined.
When you open your
eyes and you look
at something in your
immediate environment,
when you move from so-called
interoception to exteroception,
your perception of time
shifts fairly dramatically,
and you now perceive
time according to,
believe it or not,
the speed of images
moving in your environment
relative to you.
And then as you look out
further on to, say, the horizon,
you extend the time
domain even more.
If you then imagine
yourself in the whole globe,
you extend your time
domain even more.
So my morning
meditation, if you will--
it's more of a
perceptual exercise--
is to step through these
different time domains,
to close my eyes and focus on
my internal state, open my eyes
and focus on something close by,
look a little bit further, look
a bit further, think
about myself on the globe,
the whole world moving.
So you're really extending
your space domain,
and then the time
domain expands with it.
And this comes up when
you see these little memes
of, anytime you're
worried, just remember
you're a little dot on a little
blue spinning in the universe,
this kind of thing.
But you don't think that
way when you're stressed.
You're thinking,
I'm the blue dot.
You're the problem.
Whatever.
Or I want that.
You're not thinking.
So this perceptual
exercise is a way
of training my nervous
system to shift deliberately
between these
different time domains.
And for me, it's been
very useful for improving
task switching, something that,
as you probably have noticed,
I'm not very good at.
I go into the trench.
I don't leave the
trench very easily.
So that's been very useful.
And if you are interested
in more detail,
there's a wonderful book called
The Secret Pulse of Time.
And there's a Hitchcock movie
that's discussed in that book.
The movie is about
75 minutes long.
And during the
course of that movie,
the background actually
includes rising and setting
of the sun and a bunch of
different speeds of movement
and interplay between
the characters.
And your perception at
the end of the movie
is that a much, much
longer period of time
occurred because unconsciously,
your brain was paying attention
to these circadian signals
and these other signals.
Absolutely fascinating
with Hitchcock.
Not a huge Hitchcock
fan, but after seeing
that, I was like, wow.
That's genius.
He captured this
space time thing.
What you see out the window
is in one time domain.
In the room is a
difference time domain.
I won't tell you who killed who.
But it's very, very interesting.
And so the point being that when
your visual system is up close,
focusing on things up
close or internally,
you're fine slicing.
When you focus on
things further away,
you're more broadly focusing
and so on and so forth.
So that's a morning
meditation I do--
perceptual exercise.
It only takes about
a minute or so.
The other thing is that on the
monitors, they're flashing now.
That was your last question.
So I want to just say a
couple of things before we go.
First of all,
thanks to all of you
who stood out the night
for the long duration.
I realize this stuff
is nerdy detailed,
and there are a
lot of other things
you could be doing with
your evening and your time.
And so I'm very grateful that
you all came together tonight
for this what I like to
think was a discussion.
I also just want
to thank everyone
for your interest
in the podcast.
It is a labor of love.
I'm highly dependent on my
team for doing all of it.
I don't do it alone
by any stretch.
But as much as it
might seem like it's
me talking to all of you, it
really is about all of you.
That's the reason I do it,
and I'm ever so grateful.
And I'd certainly be remiss
if I didn't say thank you
for your interest in science.
[APPLAUSE]